c'est en un peu plus de deux semaines du
premier tour des municipales que jean
michel fourgous a réuni habitons et
soutien à l'hôtel de ville d'elancourt
le maire sortant se lance dans une
nouvelle campagne pour continuer de
porter ces projets dans la commune où il
est élu depuis 1996 une ville comme il
en cours ou ou
je suis quand même depuis un certain
temps où mes enfants sont nés ou willy
ont vécu et
le pouvoir par exemple changer le
système éducatif
à partir d'une en course et c'est
passionnant demain le système peut-être
de sécurité un modèle qu'on est en train
de construire on dirait qu'elles
emploient est une plate forme je dirais
d'innovation française aujourd'hui c'est
une ville à la campagne c'est une ville
assez calme en fait protéger cette ville
à la campagne fait partie des dix
priorités de la liste à elancourt mener
à bien aussi le projet de commissariats
d'agglomération qui doit voir le jour
dans la commune
étendre la police municipale au dimanche
ou encore développer un grand plan vélo
et mettre en place un budget
participatif pour cette réunion la
présidente de la région valérie pécresse
également engagé dans le scrutin dans
les yvelines est venu soutenir jean
michel fourgous on porte des fabuleux
projet pour l'avenir
le projet de la colline d'elancourt qui
va devenir la colline du vélo en
ile-de-france et en france ce sont des
magnifiques projets et je ne vous parle
pas évidemment de toute l'éducation
numérique que nous déployons lui dans
les collèges et les écoles et moi dans
les lycées de la casse qui est des
yvelines l'éducation et le numérique
sont d'ailleurs toujours au coeur des
grands projets d'al elancourt parmi les
propositions ouvrir le lab pour
accompagner les usages numériques des
familles proposés des ateliers de
robotique et de programmation enfin
tester des innovations pour adapter la
pédagogie aux enfants touchés par le
handicap